en el último par de vídeos hablé de la
regla de la cadena multivariable y que
he anotado aquí arriba y en este vídeo
quiero escribirlo connotación vectorial
y esto nos ayudará a generalizar lo para
cuando tengamos un espacio intermedio o
intermediario más bien cuando este
espacio tengan más dimensiones así que
en lugar en lugar de escribir x dt 7
como funciones separadas pensaremos en
una función que toma valores vectoriales
muy bien entonces vamos a tomar estas
funciones y las vamos a poner en una
sola función que tome valores
vectoriales que vamos a escribir digamos
como vedete muy bien y esto será un
vector que por supuesto cada componente
dependerá de t verdad y digamos cada
componente será x dt
dt muy bien entonces como podemos ver
aquí en nuestra fórmula de la regla de
la cadena multivariable aparece la
derivada de xy la derivada de y así que
sería bueno pensar por ahora cuál sería
la derivada de
esta función digamos esta función que
toma valores vectoriales verdad así que
la derivada de una función que toma
valores vectoriales y que tiene solo una
variable de entrada pues simplemente
será derivar cada una de las entradas
verdad entonces será la derivada de x
con respecto a t la derivada de jake con
respecto a t así que éstas son sus
componentes muy bien entonces viendo
esta fórmula verdad quizás ahora puedas
reconocer qué es lo que encontramos aquí
aquí tenemos la derivada de x respecto
de t múltiple multiplicado por una por
un número verdad y aquí tenemos la
derivada de y con respecto a t
multiplicada por otro número en realidad
esto lo podemos ver como un producto
punto verdad entonces esto lo podríamos
ver como el producto punto de dos
vectores podríamos poner aquí nuestro
primer vector que tiene coordenadas
parcial de f con respecto de x y parcial
de f con respecto de y ese sería nuestro
primer vector
y el producto punto con un segundo
vector que será el que tiene las
derivadas ordinarias verdad es la
derivada de x con respecto a t y la
derivada de ye con respecto a t muy bien
este producto punto nos da la fórmula
que tenemos arriba pero además estos
vectores no son elegidos digamos al azar
verdad de hecho este vector que tenemos
aquí es el gradiente de nuestra función
y esto es justamente la derivada de la
función que acabamos de escribir de este
lado entonces esto en realidad será
igual al gradiente de nuestra función f
verdad y lo multiplicamos y cuando
decimos multiplicamos es con un producto
punto por la derivada verdad que voy a
escribir así la derivada de nuestra
función b y lo escribo así sólo para
acordarnos del caso de digamos de las
funciones tradicionales verdad entonces
esto que tenemos de aquí es la fórmula
de la regla de la cadena pero en su
versión vectorial verdad es otra forma
de escribir la regla de la cadena
multivariable y de hecho para ser más
precisos tenemos que decir dónde van
evaluados verdad entonces en realidad el
gradiente de nuestra función f verdad
recordemos va evaluado en nuestras
funciones verdad x de tdt o bien que
podemos poner como ddt verdad va
evaluado en esta función y hacemos el
producto punto con la derivada de
nuestra función vectorial ve muy bien y
esto esto en realidad debería resultarte
familiar verdad cuando nosotros teníamos
el caso de funciones escalares verdad
por ejemplo si quisiéramos calcular la
derivada voy a hacerlo con otro color la
derivada con respecto de x de una
composición digamos f compuesta digamos
de esta forma con la función g x verdad
entonces nosotros sabemos que hay que
derivar la función digamos que está
afuera o la función exterior y evaluarla
en nuestra función que está dentro la
función interior y luego multiplicamos
por la derivada de la función que estaba
adentro verdad ésta
la reglada de la cadena tradicional
verdad y que de hecho es muy útil para
calcular un montón de derivadas entonces
si nosotros comparamos con esta nueva
fórmula de la de la regla de la cadena
vemos otra vez que es la misma idea de
verdad tenemos la derivada de nuestra
función f y como ya hemos mencionado la
derivada de una función de varias
digamos variables de entrada y con una
variable de salida es decir una una
función escalar verdad está representada
por el gradiente de la función y tendrá
que ir evaluado en la función o tendrá
que ir evaluada en la función que
tendríamos aquí adentro que es nuestra
función de dt y luego tenemos que
multiplicar por la derivada de la
función de adentro que es la derivada de
b pero en este caso la multiplicación de
funciones pues en realidad tiene que ser
el producto punto porque estamos
hablando de vectores verdad y esta
fórmula nos ayudará a generalizar cuando
tengamos más dimensiones entonces por
ejemplo digamos que tenemos alguna
función f
pues no sé quizás tiene por decir algo
cien cien coordenadas de entrada muy
bien tenemos 100 variables de entrada
digamos desde x1 y x2 hasta x 100 verdad
y digamos que tenemos una nueva función
vectorial vedete digamos que esta
función pues van a ser 100 funciones
verdad va a ser la función x1 dt x2 dt y
así nos seguimos hasta x
dt muy bien entonces sí nos damos cuenta
ahora con este digamos con esta nueva
nuevo espacio intermediario verdad el
que tiene 100 si en coordenadas verdad
entonces con esta con este nuevo espacio
esta fórmula aún tiene sentido verdad el
gradiente de nuestra función
efe ahora tendrá 100 componentes verdad
y tendremos que evaluarlas en esta
función verdad y luego multiplicamos por
la derivada de esta función que también
tendrá 100 componentes por lo tanto si
podemos hacer y el producto punto así
que ese es el único detalle verdad el
gradiente tendrá 100 entradas la
derivada de nuestra función vectorial b
también verdad así que esta es la
versión más general de la regla de la
cadena y lo que es genial de esta forma
en la que podemos escribirla es que se
puede ver en términos de la derivada
direccional pero yo creo que por ahora
esto es suficiente así que lo veremos en
el siguiente vídeo